hit the like button because we've
noticed uh on YouTube that some of the
algorithms have changed and this is just
an experiment if you can hit the like
button if you're watching on Rumble go
to YouTube hit like so we can see how
that affects the algorithm and if you're
listening on audio if it's apple or if
it's Spotify Google Stitcher some people
have been complaining that you know all
of a sudden nothing uploads and then
three episodes in one day the only way
we can find out is if you leave a review
and let us know how it's working for you
we're just trying to troubleshoot this
and you are the uh the population study
so hit like on YouTube leave a review if
it's working or if it's not working that
way we can fix it on with the show
[Music]
um
when you gonna be done watching that
ladder with Crowder
I done push the beds together no I was
just gonna do a stupid thing like that
I thought we could cattle cuddle I think
I won't get up and bear next to you with
them cold feet thanks to your lack of
circulation from your varicose veins
you're out of your mind
Squidward buying me Josephine
thank you for asking Josephine I hope
I've clarified that
you haven't worked one minute today
Colton I got a check didn't I
count you just got it from the mailbox
that's right I'm on disability for the
pain I feel every damn day hey my
plantar fasciitis and when I'm
gonna just be married to you shout out
yourself and join my club today at
lighter with crowder.com
it's only 89 annually you get all the
different shows now in this hand at smug
it's the nicest thing I have in my
double wide
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
ah glad to be with you today if there
are any uh technical difficulties going
on because we've swapped a toolman here
with Yakuza in their roles because we're
having an issue with YouTube it's not
playing back on YouTube for some reason
are we having it's not playing on
YouTube does that mean that we're gonna
have to stop and restart
uh if you I mean we can still play on
Rumble if you want I'm out of a job
Vault I think we should probably write
we should probably take it from the top
if we're doing this and it's not going
out there on YouTube take from the top
really quickly if we want is it is a
solvable problem is it a solvable
problem I'll have to look into it real
quick okay
I would request I would request uh do it
okay
we'll be right back enjoy this uh Indian
on screen only we don't have a budget
for an Indian no no Indian
just dude
[Music]
better
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's not funny okay fine what about this
[Music]
time
foreign
all right I apologize for that
we fixed it it's a it's exactly extreme
ownership it's my fault no it's not no
it's not no no no I was the one who I
screwed up the YouTube look at me look
at me it's not your fault
look at me
all those YouTube dicks
it's not your fault that's your flight
don't you cry about it
you don't know anything you're just some
big Tech kid uh all right so we have a
lot to get to today I'm trying to
remember where I left off because I just
took a minute and a half break but uh
hit the like button all that stuff right
now to help with the algorithm because I
apologize
I want to talk about something today uh
you know Alex Jones was on a couple of
weeks ago and that was after he had
called me beforehand you know it looks
like mask mandates are coming back in a
lot of different places across the globe
and it looks like they're going to try
and Institute them in the United States
some schools already are so we are going
to at this point the science is in the
definitive mask segment if they work if
they don't who fared better who fared
worse how they work spoiler alert no
laughs
so if you see this because I don't know
how much we're allowed to discuss this
on YouTube if you see this YouTube dump
button
head on over to rumble okay we talked
about that we'll also be talking about
Flying V Vivek for some people uh he's
been getting into it uh versus uh Eminem
also be talking about the black vote
going overwhelmingly toward Trump
because he is a rap deity I don't know
if you're familiar with this again I
grew up with hip-hop uh in third chair
we'll discuss this he has been an icon
in rap for a very long time and I think
the left ignores that at their own Peril
everyone wants to be like Trump he's
loud he's bombastic and he likes shiny
things who else would share that in
common
comment below if you can guess
Canadians
all right that and more Gerald how are
you sir I'm doing well how are you I'm
good aside from the knee thing
that popped out yeah it popped out
that's crazy it didn't wake you up
immediately you just dreamed that I
heard it in the studio and then I woke
up and I went
just like the head of anger mostly oh my
gosh I'm so frustrated that's because I
have those Jersey sheets and they're
comfortable there's no it's the friction
grabs a kneecap and it pops it out this
is a great way to start the server one
is enthralled
when you hear this that means you know
him you love them
or if you don't hear that's okay too I
don't know where it is we got new people
and all all right Saturday September
23rd at the Rosalind theater in Roslyn
Washington you can follow him on
Instagram at uh Josh underscore fire
Stein because he's a gentile Josh how
are you sir good good yeah let's we're
using that term loosely today and can I
change the song to Sound of Silence yes
yeah we already did oh yeah perfect
did I what do you guys want to switch
back do you guys want are you good are
we okay is that the problem well because
they want it we want to cross-train
people in case toolman has to not be
here but it just seems like you know oh
we could have thought this through now
we'll be discussing this uh and uh and
and more do you have anything else you
want to talk about there Gerald I feel
like I'm missing something because I'm
gonna take that break okay I think we're
fine don't worry here is I mean worry
but right off the bat uh a woman saying
the quiet part
uh look there are a lot of men who are
dejected from the dating game I
understand it uh especially a lot of
young men by the way who feel like they
have something to offer and they feel as
though they are being ignored now you
will often dismiss these people as as in
sales but the truth is it applies to a
lot of young executive men as well and
the reason for that may be because of
broads like this uh who say the quiet
part out loud I'm not joking I have
asked the last three dudes I've dated
for their bank account info on the first
date I don't judge people's actions I
look at the intention behind it so like
why do you ask for that so it's a gold
digger talking to a gay guy
you're getting straight to the point I
think you know I have a job I'm very
successful sure I think I have
everything right to be like hi are we on
the same level or am I wasting my time
probably wasting your time with everyone
would be my guess I don't know if
Starbucks is successful yes Barista hey
you got a job is this one of those only
fans people I know that's exactly what I
was thinking like Define very successful
and accountant yes exactly and an
accountant yeah she's part of the
cleanup crew here's
the problem with this is she's saying
what a lot of women think look a lot of
women want a man who is success and by
the way there's nothing there's nothing
wrong with that the issue is then
unfortunately laws that use that against
the man and that's why men just you know
this is how relationships will never be
solved in this country because those men
are going oh I don't know if I want to
sign on the dotted line because you can
leave in two weeks and take half
well it's not to mention it's kind of
creepy that you're asking for his bank
you're asking for his routing number
Social Security list of childhood pets
depending how much half is you know yeah
exactly how much do you have in savings
um yeah it's terrible you could ask that
but I get to ask other questions right
yes exactly I get to ask your body count
I get I was about to say no no don't say
that just say how many men have you
hoard around with yes check please now
hold on a second hold on a second that's
not all women okay it's just women who
sleep with men uh depending on the
financial gain involved in the scenario
that's why I was saying yeah yeah
specific it's the oldest profession
known to man it is I mean only fans is
just an extension of that and she's
successful is she do you know what she
does do we know what this woman does
both of them
the foundation of society will crumble
if this is how people are approaching
relationships if it is a transactional
relationship yeah as it is for not all
women just to be clear but women like
that there are enough there are more
women like that out there
then required for it to be significant
in impacting the mail dating pool let me
put it that way there are enough women
out there like that that men are saying
I'm not getting married ever right and
then women say well there's no one to
marry well maybe it's because you asked
him for his routing number
ridiculous
can you let me know ladies men comment
but what's it like out there what's it
like out there in the dating pool these
days it's got to be a pride swallowing
Siege I love how gingersnap got angry
women are the worst and then Nancy was
right now she's like easy we're like not
all women it's just his generation she
goes easy
I like the idea of her being on a date
with a guy and he's proud to show his
bank statement and it's just terrible
it's just like it's in the negative he's
like yeah you got a job you're
successful what's up man it would be
great if he just shows her his
Investment Portfolio and he's worth like
hundreds of millions and then he goes
Dutch on the bill yes
yeah I'll show it to you but you got to
pay half yeah exactly like there you go
yes hey look at all this yeah wouldn't
it be nice wouldn't it yeah we're gonna
go have these
friends yeah
and how many negliges do you need by the
way it's a live show Monday through
Friday 10 a.m Eastern I guarantee you
that on a technical level it's usually
far more proficient than today now let's
go on to uh Vivek is it vivec Vivek is
that it's pronounced um he's been
obviously right now on a big tour he's
been gaining momentum since the debates
uh the polls show the vast majority of
people think that he won that debate
comment below comment below I'd like to
hear from you a lot of people are
concerned that maybe he's not as genuine
as they would like that maybe he's sort
of learned the talking points again I'd
Reserve judgment I don't necessarily
know but I think he's he's pretty
articulate and he's not afraid to take
the fight to uh his opposition when it
counts uh but of course
um he did make the mistake of showing
the country his uh rap skills and not
everyone is impressed including Eminem
which brings us to the latest edition of
The Flying bee
[Applause]
[Music]
it still doesn't work yeah it never
works no so Eminem
the rapper oh thank you yeah yeah
helpful uh and I'm from Canada where
Eminem used to sell Burgers it was a
store that would sell meat yeah Eminem
yeah I know it was a big thing comment
if you're from Canada you remember that
meat and meat yeah exactly I don't even
know it was probably a French thing but
Eminem's not happy uh he's never happy I
don't think he's ever been out I've
never heard him issue a happy rap but
again it's it's an angry medium when you
think about it he's not happy with Vivek
uh having Vivek sorry having uh
performed rap uh on tour at the Iowa
State Fair I think we have a clip of the
rep and I will say Eminem's
a dick
but I'm not a big fan of it either
he did it with lyrics on
he didn't even get a karaoke track
can someone get a Korean as an advisor
in an Asian somewhere no no no no no
sing with lyrics look very stupid
Eminem better so Vivek was issued a
cease and desist letter from Eminem and
this is not new they did it with
Barracuda and Sarah Palin at one point
that's true uh you can get into the law
and technically he's allowed to do it at
rallies depending on who you ask but the
issue is it's just kind of embarrassing
so I think he just agreed that all right
he's not going to do it yeah but look
everybody was up in arms about this when
he came and I was like it didn't bother
me of course he's not a good rapper I
didn't mind it though I was just like ah
whatever I wouldn't ask this guy to come
rap for me but he's a young guy and he's
trying to seem young on the campaign
trip I got it yeah I minded it yeah
just because it was really bad it was so
bad it was really bad
karaoke night at the fair can you guys
is it okay can we do this is it okay
because hey I like this guy I certainly
vote for him over over I was about to
say Obama over former Vice President Joe
Biden yes but uh probably leaves the
rapping at home it doesn't work it's
don't give the left don't give your
opposition a layup it it isn't good well
he would just say hey uh we we saw that
you couldn't rap and he's like yes I
Can't Rap I'm running for president not
rapper yeah
all right come on lay down this track
it's gonna be hot yeah but first let me
talk to you about late term abortion no
that's not what about you doesn't even
rhyme with it yeah see that's what I
don't want to happen what you just did I
was making the point do you have the
admonish button for Gerald today I know
you're kind of new to this thing if you
can't find it we'll just have to move on
watch your mouth he gets in the
tricaster he thinks he can tell I know
here's the thing though you can't blame
the Flying V look he's the lover of good
music he
there's something lost in in in in in
Translation culturally he he grew up
listening to this
[Music]
hold on is that real by the way the rest
of the top 40 sounds the exact same it's
definitely real that's a solo career
he's been a group called The Basmati
boys
[Laughter]
that's awesome little Curry
you tell me that's real
I'm the Ambassador
it's in my life it's mighty boys smash
the rumble button right now if you're
watching on Rumble because uh you know I
don't really know how much the rumble
button does on Rumble but it's fun on
YouTube the likes we want to see what
happens there with our algorithm because
they obviously don't like what it is so
anyway Vivek agreed to stop using the
song and he posted this tweet he said
will The Real Slim Shady please stand up
he didn't just say what I think he did
did he that's great that's really that's
way better than the wrap yeah I guess I
don't know this is not he's not the
first guy by the way he's not the first
politician to fail at a rap career
wow
stuck the r yeah I know someone didn't
give him the uh someone didn't give him
sort of the rule book ah
the uh is operative play it again okay
why not right we already have another
mirror we don't need any more you're a
big shots Mr President it's kind of good
beat
again
we already have a mayor and we
don't need any more you're a big shot
once more that's catchy
we already have a man we don't
need any more you're a big shot he said
he said
oh man people wanna and by the way you
will see people say that we are more
racist for making fun of him for having
done that I get it but he was quoting
someone else not all the times he
dropped the n-bomb but
one more time
we already have another man we don't
need any more your big shots I don't
want any more racist gotchas with anyone
nope he didn't stutter there either no
he didn't he just kind of nailed it it
was the one word where he didn't stutter
it's if I look directly at what Clarence
Thomas at the time yeah uh there was uh
there were a few times that he used it
it's hard for me to keep track there
were at least two or three times that he
used it he also said he didn't want his
children raised in a uh in a racial
jungle ah oh yes oh yeah he's a bad
person Josh I'd rather raise his
children in the shower with himself yes
exactly see that story that's not so
much raising as it is rearing oh
tomato tomato could everyone just decide
we're gonna have a miserable day today
come on that's it everyone's like
it Gerald what are we chill come on
let's get this straight back
you guys are offended at that no he
showered with his daughter yeah and it
was it was in her diary which they took
they rated James O'Keefe's house took it
claimed it was still they never said
that it wasn't true and then it
confirmed like oh yeah it's really her
diary and she did talk about how her dad
showered with her long after it was
appropriate as well as her being
molested by other people and no one in
the media wants to ask this guy about it
you want to talk about living in Crazy
World you want to know how crazy this
world is not only that diary but they
are going after every single person any
celebrity who manages to say something
that might be slightly offensive or
really let's just say out of touch or
maybe not with the times meanwhile the
guy who they want to run in the next
election
did run it again
we already have a Marin we don't
need any more your big shots and here's
the thing I don't think he's a racist I
think he's an idiot I'm just saying that
if we want to play by your rules don't
forget don't forget don't that he did
this again
is there a memory
we don't need any more you're a big
shots it's okay that's what we call a
remix he remixed
basically
rap no thank you no no no absolutely not
Megan rap now are you about to say
something there Joe I was gonna say
about that my offense was not at you
saying it was at him doing it yes I know
yeah yeah at him rearing his rearing his
oh rearing his children in the shower
maybe we need to hit the YouTube button
I don't care
do you think this is bad tune in to Nick
depaolo tonight at 5 p.m on Monday okay
we're crying out loud he'll probably
watch this show but yeah those cowards
go on so this is something that is isn't
interesting we talked about this
yesterday people said you know what I'd
like to see a segment on that Donald
Trump a lot of people don't realize this
um not only is he more popular in the
black community than the media wants you
to think and we're doing these new
segments black and white and the gray
issues you can comment what you'd like
to hear us discuss it's just we go out
to a black area of town and discuss
issues and you'd be surprised as to how
much Common Ground we find but he's
actually been an icon specifically in
the hip-hop Community for a very long
time anyone who has listened to hip-hop
growing up certainly in you know the 90s
and early 2000s would know that but the
media again I didn't fully understand
what gaslighting meant now I do so let
me first give you some stats as far as
the voting Block in 2020 he won the most
black voters for anyone in the GOP since
1984. wow and here's something pretty
significant Donald Trump gained in urban
areas overall right between his election
so like Milwaukee plus 3000 Detroit plus
five Philadelphia plus 21 000 New York
City Plus 76 000. yeah he was gaining
significantly in urban areas and that's
why it was so weird when there was the
voting anomaly of the safest and most
secure election of all time in Detroit
where he was winning in Wayne County by
a bigger margin than before had made
these improvements until the votes
switched now here's the thing when
people Gaslight you I don't want to go
into a rant on Election interference but
we're allowed to say it on YouTube right
now I guess now forevermore by the way
thank you thank you mug Club you guys
can join up because we said we're going
to do it anyway and they can't suspend
you all they even said so they can't
suspend all conservatives so now they
have to allow it because a significant
portion of the country doesn't believe
that the election was the most free Fair
secure of all time
um for it to work in other words when
someone says you are crazy you have to
look at where Donald Trump was
performing how he was performing in
these areas particularly areas where he
was expected to lose in tandem with the
areas that he had already won okay
for the Detroit flip to work at the same
time as the red wagons came in with
votes and the Bristol boards went up
um you would have to believe that all
mail-in voting
would be over 96 percent for Joe Biden
that's the only way the numbers make
sense in that vote flip there is no
other way for it to make sense if you
believe that
you comment below as to what you think
is a more reasonable opinion we covered
it live all right back to hip-hop back
to rappers not vivec we moved on from
here which I listened to in the 90s so I
feel like you listen to Vivek in the 90s
weird that's like Kamala Harris
listening to Tupac in the 70s remember I
listened to Tupac a lot of Biggie High
School
what
mayor Willie Brown rattled your brain so
well endowed that headboard has dents
[Laughter]
the prize rappers have been not only
praising but using Trump as an icon
since going back to the fall of the
Berlin Wall
[Music]
resurrection of the real time to get
richer than Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
Donald Trump
so white that's my point it's terrible
you're doing the same thing expecting
different results it's always going to
be a bad result that's the definition
this should stop I get that you played
football with black guys
there were some white guys he's a nasty
person this picture I'm walking up to
the o line I'm like Donald it's like
shut up
just get over there to Corner position
yes you didn't even know what you're
talking about here's some numbers all
references are available to letter with
credit.com we have the link uh there in
the description since 1989 Donald Trump
has been featured in over 260 songs and
by the way that's just before his
presidency 60 more songs after elected
so well over 300 songs and of course
this isn't an extensive list I'm willing
to bet it's significantly higher for you
to go through all the independent music
out there uh I mean they they
particularly love Trump rappers
especially love Trump he is the wealthy
guy who they have consistently pointed
to so let's just go back to like 89 he
had three uh rappers or rap groups by
the way who mentioned from you Beastie
Boys he had Fat Boys he had Donald D you
have some other rappers who mentioned
him many times like Rick Ross nine songs
Nas you guys can go arguably the great
arguably the goat some people will claim
that seven songs or you have Young Thug
six songs Lil Wayne five songs Raekwon
five songs so it's a repeated theme that
has been going on and this is why some
of the new shifts shouldn't be all that
surprising to you and I do think it's
Unique to Donald Trump this is something
that you can't just take for granted
they've also been by the way hilarious
viral memes remixes uh one as recent as
this week actually about the the Georgia
indictment
[Music]
[Laughter]
the dance moves are great I don't think
you could do that with any other
president no it wouldn't be as fun no it
wouldn't be as fun like it's it's kind
of tongue-in-cheek but it also kind of
works like I could picture him showing
up like I forgot I let him hit Vince
McMahon with a folding chair this is a
guy who loved being in the spotlight and
he likes bling is it any surprise that a
lot of people in the RAP Community like
Donald Trump I think it's kind of funny
though that you were saying Vivek can't
do that rap When Donald Trump can do the
chicken wrap on SNL and he can do stuff
like this you're like ah it kind of
works yes yes because he's self he's
self-aware enough maybe that's true
maybe maybe that's the problem Vivek was
doing it seriously and I like Vivek just
to be clear just stop cute just stop
what's happening and Trump by the way
also got support from a bunch of famous
rappers up to 2020 election you have ice
cube you have Lil Wayne you have Lil
pump there's always a little little hey
sorry Stephen at the use of the restroom
do you yeah I'm sorry I I know we got
another day I know that's fine that's
fine go ahead Josh look when you gotta
go you gotta go uh by the way he still
has support from some rappers to be
clear yeah yeah you can go it's fine
it's people know it's life uh there's
the baby there's Benny The Butcher
there's Kodak Black Benny The Butcher
and a big reason people like him Hey
look it's also his policies right a
rising type you know raises All Ships
just to be clear lifts all boats sorry
um yeah you can admonish me I messed up
that expression right there I sounded
like my mom okay it works a rising tide
is is make a boat go go on
so
no wonder they love him not just because
of the fact that all black Americans
benefited under the presidency of Donald
Trump uh compared to the former vice
presidency of Biden but his his specific
policies in reaching out to the black
community for example he freed rappers
from prison like uh like ASAP Rocky I
spoke soon to thank him you know dude
Trump boy just the White House I don't
think there's nothing wrong with that
pardon rappers uh Lil Wayne Kodak Black
just to be clear and again this does
matter it may seem like okay these are
just sort of isolated incidents but
the simple Act of reaching out to a
community that has been written off and
I'm not saying that you're going to
change the demographic of black
votership but having spent a lot of time
again in these communities and again
coming up from the stand-up Community
where you have a very high percentage of
performers who are black you'd be
surprised as to where you can find some
common ground today today in the United
States of America I'm not talking about
black lives matter Inc the average black
American
is the moderate weighing of the Democrat
Party just to be clear so even if
they're voting Democrat they're not on
board with all of the crazy woke
policies I don't hold grudges against
anybody
okay
and Donald Trump by the way even reaches
out and gives a top shelf Financial
advice to some of these hip-hop artists
stop putting everything in your name
create a business LLC put everything in
LLC and open up a c courtroom if you
don't know you need to figure these out
I'm telling you the names get a c
corporate running LLC you're gonna make
it even deeper go get a trust fund and
run a Corp that runs the LLC you want to
get even deeper on two trust funds for
your business and your person to run
that trust that runs all the business it
can get deep my God absolutely Donald
Trump actually showed me that message
that's why he didn't pay tax
except for the incriminating part well
it's the tax evasion issue but this is
also something that's important too
sometimes people don't fully understand
like the hip-hop Community it's the same
I've talked
for I had a guy who would uh come to my
house he'd come to your house to work on
your car guy didn't have any teeth and I
mean that he had no he had one tooth one
tooth he had one tooth he called it old
toothy it's almost worse and you could
barely understand him but I found out he
was a genius he was a genius and some
people look there's a cultural
disconnect where you may hear people
speak in a certain way and think oh that
person's an idiot where you have a lot
of people in the hip-hop Community who
are close to being billionaires or
certainly multi-hundred millionaires now
some of you may disagree with how
they've made their money but here's the
thing they're not dumb people just
because they speak a different lingo and
that's something that Donald Trump has
not only understood but he's willing to
engage yeah I have no idea how much
advice he's given to hip-hop artists but
I bet you I bet it was it was enough but
tell him he was shot in the face 50. you
need a baxter everyone needs a backstory
face shooting you know he would sit down
in a room and be just as comfortable
with a rapper as a politician or a
businessman that he would normally run
into so but I think you're right he did
reach out to the community and it
doesn't take much to go hey
I'm hearing what you're saying yeah like
I know the rest of these people like the
AL sharptons of the world and the Barack
Obamas of the world will say all of
these wonderful things about what
they're going to do for your community
raise a bunch of money and then leave
but I'm actually doing something for
your community right by taking care of
this problem that's what he was good at
yeah and it didn't take a whole lot I'm
sure he'll Pander a little bit of course
he's a politician at that time he spoke
in Phoenix he said let me tell you
Wu-Tang ain't nothing to with whoa
what they're not even from here that's
what old dirty bastard is my favorite I
don't know maybe I like there is a which
is a method man I don't know who's your
favorite they're my favorite too
is Josh by the way still in the bathroom
oh Yakuza he should be back man go go go
find her he's okay
[Music]
hey Josh don't come in my office for a
second yeah sure excellent
please sit down what's up Sam nothing
much
just figured we could uh you know give
it to a little bit uh you know as they
say uh Dimension
you know that kind of thing yeah it's
cool to kick back and relax a little bit
sure sure definitely do you like that
especially for lunch oh yeah it was
great man oh a little spicy for my taste
but I ate it all yeah so I want to ask
you um my people they came from uh
kaletsk uh where are your people
originate
what do you mean were your people from
uh jeancoya
vitepsk uh Eric Israel
Seattle oh
yeah wait Sam I'm not Jewish
but Josh firestein no it's firestein
it's not Firestone yeah oh the guy first
time oh yeah okay
get out
shoot really hard
you can leave get out you whoa damn
whoa is everything cool in here oh this
guy he really isn't you're right I know
you should have known you know what Sam
his blood will be on your hands you
remember that both of your mumsers get
out and your children's Children's hands
all of them you you Tweed where
out putters
[Music]
I'm sorry Josh you shouldn't don't allow
him to pull you in there no no what
I didn't know he was gonna do that don't
allow him to suck you into a Semitic
Vortex I didn't know there's a gift yeah
well if you'd stayed around oh there's
probably something like a yamaker it's
cheap Menorah all right
that's because I feel like there's a lot
of information and sometimes again
you're too close to the forest but I'm
not going to mess up another expression
but uh you lose the bird's eye view
masks we've gone back and forth so much
and now we're talking about whether
there will be new mask mandates where
the good news is we have a very uh with
a very large set of data now to work
with I know it's not a clinical trial
but again you're not gonna have the gold
standard travel with them what would be
the placebo with a mask just a mask with
holes in it like it was Chris Cuomo's
that he pinned up against his artboard
my point is we have to kind of go by
population studies and we have the
definitive answer so as we Face new mask
mandates or potential lockdowns and by
the way comment below not if you'll do
it but if you think that we're at a
point in this country where a majority
of people won't if you think most people
will go along with it or they I tend to
think we're at a point where there won't
be enough people who will go along with
it which I think is a silver lining
people have learned
so how many times though with that being
said have you heard over the past few
years and we will go through the myths
the claims all of it references are
available you've heard them say that
masks save lives and in case you haven't
heard it recently because the science
are really just science right not the
science copyright science says that it's
not correct here's a reminder of what it
sounded like then the CDC is now
recommending that people including those
vaccinated go back to wearing masks
indoors in regions of the country that
are seeing substantial or high rates of
covid-19 spread the World Health
Organization is urging fully vaccinated
people to continue wearing masks as the
Delta variant spreads worldwide masks
matter these Mass they matter it matters
and saves lives it prevents the spread
of the disease so if you have a physical
covering with one layer you put another
layer on it just makes common sense that
it likely would be more effective and
that's the reason why you see people
either double masking or doing a
don't let covid win wear a mask
the science right Mr fauci there just
immediately making a logical leap if the
science shows that one condom helps then
two would just make sense never mind the
friction would cause them to create
micro tears
I always wear two pair of underwears
yeah yeah true is more
my problem solved
well then you've got to wear six because
it's more than five and if five is good
then six is better
he just obviously if one works then two
will work better
no evidence at that point
and you dummies went along with it not
you watching right now but a good
portion of this country I hope you feel
stupid I really do I get it like oh we
want it it's an olive branch but you
also sometimes have to rub their face in
their piss I really hope you feel dumb
that you followed that guy knowing what
we know now you could rub their facing
it all they want they got five masks on
it they're gonna mask six is the magic
number we're past five as we go into
this just really quickly currently right
now Lionsgate has a mask mandate that
they just put back into effect for I
believe their Santa Monica offices
anybody that goes into the office has to
have a mask in a university in Atlanta
basically said we're gonna mass for the
next two weeks there's no parties yeah
that's gonna work on a college campus no
parties or large Gatherings and
everybody has to go back to wearing a
mask so we're not talk like this is
again Alex Jones it's happening with
private companies but again that's just
they're testing it yeah they're testing
it and of course what happens there this
happens with private companies then it
would extend to federal employees if
they can get away with it and then they
want to see what they can do with the
population they don't want to overreach
if they think that you'll push back
enough which is why you have to be as
vocal as possible and fight like hell
okay what's the science what science do
we have on mass now well let me just
rapid fire this for you and the
references are available okay key factor
number one masks we now know
can actually and by can I mean are
actually poisonous so here's a new study
that came out here in the last couple of
weeks researchers at uh June Book
University their k94 which by the way
are very similar to The n95 Masks they
were found to release high levels of
volatile organic compounds you've heard
the term tvoc right so eight times the
recommended safety limit we think that's
that sounds bad eight times is more than
seven
but in this case it's bad so can we just
round that down to zero no Fouch you
can't just manipulate it anymore
but I'm also the math so these compounds
by the way what kind of symptoms
difficulty breathing nervous system
damage organ damage potentially cancer
just to be clear what all that being
true masks maybe should be appropriate
for some folks
I need my hair done now
so think about this eight times the
recommended safety limit now here's the
deal this is the hypocrisy that you see
or you know what not the hypocrisy
everyone's a hypocrite
the mental loop-de-loops that people on
the left would make the these are people
by the way who will buy organic fruits
because they don't want to ingest
pesticides I don't know if you know this
but by the way organic foods that you
buy at the grocery store they can use
pesticides uh these are people who
refuse to drink from plastic bottles
because of the infinitesimal chance that
they might consume some xenoestrogens or
through the BPA which could somehow
disrupt their endocrine system when
inhaling directly two inches away eight
times the recommended safety limit of
volatile organic compounds however it's
time to trust Dr fauci commonly referred
to as the science also ASAP pricky now
it's science
and by the way we've lived it this might
actually explain we had we had one
employee remember it was terrified we
the one employee who refused to ever
take off his mask
[Music]
I thought he was on paternity leave well
me too he's up in the Loft she's living
life on his own terms I like it you know
what it smells it doesn't play by
anyone's rules yeah
number two okay mask we now know
remember we did this in schools but they
hurt children in a multitative ways
measurable ways quantifiable ways one of
the ones that pisses me off the most
remember they would always say hey what
harm is it oh if we lock everything down
look it's just a safety measure at this
point air on the side of safety as
though there were no consequences as
though fundamentally altering our
economy was not a consequence hey look
air in the side of safety right so kids
work so kids do their class by Zoom a
little bit how did masks hurt them well
lockdowns hurt them mentally by the way
we've now seen record numbers of
inhibited emotional development yeah
we've seen slower language development
also if kids wear the mask too long they
could end up looking like this that's a
problem that we deal with ah
psychologically we've seen increased
anxiety we've seen increased stress
we've also seen by the way children from
these lockdown periods in mass as they
go into adulthood and into Universe
we've seen higher substance abuse we've
seen higher rates of mood disorders by
the way to a statistical degree that
couldn't be explained any other way and
when you add all of these together that
follow the same Trend that's where it
you see a very clear causation we also
have very physical manifestations
breathing discomfort that kids went
through skin disorders headaches
these increased dramatically these were
reported and now we have study not just
self-reporting but we have studies
looking at the entire population we've
collected the data there's a trend
across the board everywhere that masks
were implemented so when people say oh
how does it hurt you it hurts a lot of
people in a lot of ways it is not
consequence free exactly and so one of
the videos that actually made me the
most frustrated about this entire thing
because we knew that this was BS right
and adults get to make an informed
decision you can go along with it
wearing a mask wasn't the worst thing in
the world you thought until we had some
of this data come out right as an adult
but as a child there were videos of kids
who you know this like don't want to
wear a mask and they're too young to
understand what you're trying to do and
so they just cry and cry and cry and try
to rip it off and try to like
instinctively they're like no this is
wrong yeah and there's kids crying and
we knew as adults they're at
statistically zero risk from covid
statistically zero chance of them dying
from covid and yet we're masking them
and forcing them to do this and they're
crying through the entire process that
really pissed me off because if you're
an adult and you want to make this
decision fine but the kids the innocent
people like we're supposed to fight for
them and protect them and say no I'm
this is not happening yeah you can't do
this because this kid is not you know
what else it highlights you know first
off I'm going to get to another fact
that they don't even work in case you
think that all of this is worth it it's
not because they don't even work but
parents need to fight for their you know
who is fighting against the children
nobody's fighting against children
teachers unions yep the true the real
heroes the real pronounce it yeah the
real heroes yes the teachers saying if
it were up to the teachers unions they
wouldn't be back
today
still be wearing masks at least
my life I'm risking my life going in
with a bunch of preschoolers if they're
not double masking meanwhile the kids
don't learn how to read body language
facial expressions they don't learn how
to interact with you that's a huge
component right seeing a smile seeing
how someone is interacting with you
these are these are known facts or at
least they were up until the pandemic
where we said ah what's the worst come
on it's consequence three it's just a
mask it's not just a mask and it's about
the control that the mask represents and
it's compounded by the fact that they
don't even work because here is key fact
number three
according to the Cochrane report
I know we are all children not ring so
Rye ten studies took place in the
community two studies and health care
workers compared with wearing no mask in
the community studies only wearing a
mask may make a little to no difference
in how many people caught a flu-like
illness or coveted-like illness we've
had many studies here this is another uh
another key Point according to Oxford
epidemiologist Tom Jefferson not the guy
who you know wait a second not Thomas I
know it's confusing he's an Oxford man
yeah Tom Jefferson
there is just no evidence that they
meaning masks make any difference full
stop just to be clear boom go read that
article but here's something else just
to be clear there was no difference
between masking and not masking school
districts there was no statistical
difference
um the best that you can find is maybe
just to be clear and you know what else
didn't work social distancing like this
this is something we actually did in
case you've forgotten how stupid stupid
my helicopter's here
that's unbelievable and what the left is
trying to say to you right they'll try
and say well all these studies are
population studies these ju you can tell
people that they should wear a mask but
you don't know if these districts are
wearing masks for example I think there
was I'm going by Road here there was a
study in Peru where they would say yeah
but we did see that the the no masking
districts either had better results or
the differences were negligible but we
don't know if they were wearing mask or
they weren't well guess what that also
means that you don't know if the pro
mask Community was wearing it or not so
all you know is when you study the
population at large is at best it is
inconclusive data but everything that we
seem to know when we collect all of the
data right when you have this when you
have this preponderance of evidence is
that at best there is no difference and
we absolutely know the negative side
effects that come with masking
particularly with children not to
mention what they do to society as a
whole now the argument that they will
try and make is well hold on a second
these are population studies but in a
lab setting and I want you to watch this
then see if you can catch the stupid
because they think that this is a strong
counter argument in a lab in these
perfect conditions actually a mask works
so you can't say that masks don't work
in the population at large if everyone
did this
[Music]
so it shows there and by the way early
on in in the uh I think it was Jacob was
selling some of like basic hot mess
where we did we said hey look it the one
thing that I'm asked me to do is if you
are sick you wear it it might help
prevent you spreading the and that still
is true if you wear a mask now as far as
you being protected by a mask so let's
watch that again and I want you to think
of this is in a lab right it has been
put on the face absolutely sealed I know
this is showing how it's it's stopping
particles from being propelled but they
also want you to believe or at least
still to this day most people believe it
also prevents you from inhaling
particles right so let's assume If This
Were In Reverse that that was the case
and then I'm going to change one
variable watch it again
God bless you
finally somebody did
[Music]
wait some particles still go out and it
only takes one it's like AIDS in the
cereal box remember that fouchy so it's
going out no they're starting with a
mask okay let me change one thing you're
in a room where other people have
coveted and particles are out there The
Mask has not been
on your face the entire day without ever
having been touched or removed so let's
say if at any point during that day
assuming by the way this is still a
brand new mask right you're not reusing
one there are particles around
oh hold on let me scratch my nose ah
particles are now on the inside of your
mask and you're inhaling them along with
eight times the legally permissible
limit of volatile volatile organic
compounds just one pull it down guess
what those particles are now in The Mask
yeah touch it oh now that's on the mess
did you ever take it off did you ever
reuse a mask let's be honest you had
your mask stuffed into your glove
compartment next to whatever other crap
you put in there my pocket yeah it looks
like you ate a cheese enchilada through
your mask yes sometimes listen this is
the point and and recently I had a
conversation with uh with my wife about
this but this is how I found out about
it she's a nurse obviously we talked
about this she said
nurses around the country this is not
what she said but based on her
information nurses around the country
should have stood up and said whoa whoa
whoa hold on that's not right right we
train specifically to make sure that we
either use a mask properly or do not use
a mask at all because if you use a mask
improperly it's actually more dangerous
than not having any protection at all of
course right every single nurse in
America should have been going whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa time out time out we're
telling people the wrong things this is
going to actually lead them to more harm
because they're going to wear masks
improperly and think they're safe and
they're not well those shitty tick tocks
weren't going to make themselves Gerald
dancing bodies and I get it oh my gosh
the true heroes yeah go tell that to the
guy who still has black lung because he
was working at Ground Zero months after
the towers fell yeah by the way do you
see that the CDC sent out like an alert
saying hey masks won't work for smoke
particles because they're too small
and they'll get through the masks when I
think the covid molecule particle is
like 200 times smaller let's put the
difference I cut a hole in my mask for
my cigar
I got one in my mask too but it's a
little bigger unbelievable whoa it's for
cheeseburgers that's the Wall To Your
Den now
and by the way if you're watching
comment did you ever buy this the mass
thing and hit the like button because
this will probably be clipped into a bit
this is
as definitive as we can get we want to
go through okay is there harm yes do
masks work no and now let's get to key
factor number four the studies that they
tried to use uh to show that they worked
were flawed yeah right they were flawed
from the get-go so what they'll say is
hey population studies don't really
count let's look at masks in a lab well
we just went through that right because
that does not apply when we look at
across the board with population city
however when to make their argument and
by that I mean leftist communist
bastards they Point yet again to another
population study Bangladesh
hmm okay and this is these you read this
in Washington Post it says Villages
where surgical masks were distributed
appeared to be especially protected and
effect concentrated in the most
vulnerable populations we found that
surgical masks averted one in three
symptomatic infections among those aged
60 and older okay so that went on in
Washington Post
problem a re-analysis showed that the
study had flaws here you go here's a
re-analysis it says it would not be
reasonable to conclude from this trial
that there's a direct causal link
between mask wearing and any causal
claims it is critical to consider that
all of the outcomes in the study are
based on self-reporting of symptoms
meaning that doesn't even necessarily
need to include a covid test which was
also faulty
there's no point of entry here where you
can make a definitive claim you
absolutely can if you study what is
being inhaled from these masks time the
per eight times the permissible limit
but as far as any entry okay where the
coveted tests accurate No they were not
was the death reporting accurate well
concerned that one guy was listed as a
covet death who shot himself in the head
with a shotgun uh no they were not and
now we have to say Okay was the mask
data accurate No we now know that they
were not especially in this case one
study in Bangladesh which they point to
was based on
self-reporting why would you do that and
why would you point to that as your
study while ignoring the other ones
unless you were intentionally trying to
be dishonest Washington Post I know I'm
asking a question I already know the
answer to here's another quote our
analysis of the population size shows
that behavioral biases can produce a
highly significant a nine percent
difference between the control and
intervention arm in the absence of any
causal link with the intervention in
other words you can't use population
studies except for Bangladesh which by
the way is entire fairly self-reported
we didn't even effectively administer
covet tests which also don't work
tell me you're lying without telling me
you're lying it's unbelievable
unbelievable the entire world because of
this the entire world shuts down and
makes everybody wear masks and go
through the problem we just discussed
all of the problems that that has caused
societally yeah and they're doing it
again they want to do it again well no
no no no no no no no no no doing it well
they're doing it within their company
but they would like to do it on a
national scale I know but for me that is
doing it again because it's like oh
they're doing it in their companies I
get it but what are you going to do quit
your job and go find another job yes but
that takes time and so essentially you
don't have to do it through the
government you just have to do well the
reason I said is because the left is
going to say oh okay they're not doing
any lockdowns again the only reason why
is because of people like us let's be
honest if you had your way completely
unfettered we would be locked down it
would happen again it would happen every
single time there's a new epidemic just
to be clear it's not what's the left
does with their power it's what would
they do if left completely unfettered
the closest thing that we have as an
example
is prime minister blackface himself
Trudeau look at what he did
and that's what the left would at least
do if there were no checks and balances
in our system and by the way this one's
just for the people who still say well
still I don't really care if our kids
are can't you know if they're if they're
if they're cancer stricken and
um
it still seems to me like it's the juice
is worth the squeeze especially if I
ignore the signs all right well then
this one is for you uh key fact number
five I don't really care about this here
you can hit that Yakuza key fact number
five masks are a major pollutant I don't
know if you know this again masks cannot
be reused
no yeah I mean you think you can reuse
them but remember everyone mocks Donald
Trump when he says there's a way to
sanitize so we could actually reuse
these Maps that's the finest liquids
think about the planet which by the way
we actually have that here now I have a
we have a steam closet save this money
on dry cleaning and actually like a
sanitization cycle nice I've never used
it because I don't trust it but
let me hop in there math sorry it's not
big enough it's not for human years
I don't know I mean it's not yes not for
generals we've tried I've tried trust me
please no no it's not a that's not an
indictment on you it's like even a
wouldn't be able to fit in there
yeah we tried so yeah we did try for
people who care about there are no con
okay 2020 alone 1.6 billion masks
entered the world's oceans and by 2022
the world is throwing away about 3
million masks
per minute I don't know if that even
seems right that's from Business Insider
that's what they say but it sounds
extreme it's got to be right yeah yeah
it's Business Insider so you know it's
good like five or six billion people
using masks every day and throwing them
away right now here's multiple times a
day that sounds right well also there's
also uh Mr Masky MC throwerson who just
that's what he does yeah
I don't know why
yeah exactly all he's doing just
throwing masks all the time big and
Sheboygan yeah very big in Japan
so here's something again it's not you
don't you don't measure uh a man
um by what he believes or what he
applies as far as ethics is whether they
are ever applied equally everyone's a
hypocrite but is this person at least
attempting to apply their logic yeah or
their moral filter equally Okay so
450 years is a number as far as how long
it takes takes for these masks to
decompose wow I know some of you say who
cares screw the turtles I agree
they're gonna think we're so stupid well
the fish will never considering that
plastic straws take allegedly 200 years
I'm not a mathematician that's less than
half the time of a mask to decompose and
because of the fact that people are so
up in arms about plastic straws taking
200 years to decompose everything tastes
like a number two pencil wanna have to
drink through one of these stupid wooden
straws but you're throwing out three
million masks per minute
so let me just recap this for you
whenever someone thinks that you're
stupid enough to buy the mask
in conclusion and I'm getting very near
the end of this now what do we know
masks are poisonous that's irrefutable
all these references are louder with
credit.com they harm children mentally
emotionally and physically they do not
work according to all the conclusive
data that we have the data that would
say they work is supported by bad
research and has been fact checked and
it is worse for the environment than
anything else you can possibly do you
would be less of a dick to the
environment if you were driving a diesel
truck while spraying an aerosol kid out
the window like it's your job
they're hiring yeah in Oregon for that
there's a yeah there's a specific
business it's an air freshener because
that place smells right oh no no it's a
whole it's a whole environmental but
yeah kind of secret actually uh is it
yeah it's not that secret now because
you're just talking about it I don't
really think of this Josh I'm calling
you on this okay we can move on you know
I will put you in the state closet give
me the details
we'll do the reverse team it has it has
a it has a moisture suck it's a
dehumidifier too you'll come out looking
like a poddling after Pelosi's been here
with you a little raisin a little prune
think about this though where we are as
a country at this point they want you to
not they want you to not eat steak for
the environment and three million masks
being 450 years to decompose none of
this is real look you're not being a
conspiracy theorist when you notice the
trend that hold on a second when they're
doing something for the environment you
lose more freedoms and then when they're
disregarding the environment it's
because for the greater good you need to
lose more more freedom yeah on no side
of this equation tell me this outside of
the ability to kill your baby which I
would argue removes the freedoms from
the baby you can comment below when
we're talking about particularly late
term abortion if you disagree with that
outside of that
where does the left ever oh and the
ability to to to do drugs of course the
ability to do drugs because they can tax
it okay outside of things that harm your
body or other bodies like abortion
murder outside of that
when does the left ever end up with a
policy that gives you more freedom
accidentally
yeah what's what you choose to eat no
what you choose to drive no what school
you can go to no how you can raise your
own kids no whether you can wear a mask
or not no but and even though it's worse
for the environment no we're still going
to remove that freedom well it's like
that is it's not as though it's a
consequence it's not as though it's a
side effect it's as though it's the
starting point and that's why you don't
go along with the message you don't go
along because there's no science behind
it you don't go along because it's
but you also don't go along
because we've seen what happens the
minute they get a little bit of control
the next moment you know
you're choking a turtle with three
million masks per minute being tossed
into the ocean while you eat Cricket
Burgers convincing yourself that it's
just as good as ground round it's
horseshit and you don't need to be
ashamed to not go along with it all
right we're going to continue this
you're going to do a segment I guess on
I guess Spaniards kissing Sports
and if you have not joined a mug club
yet you get Nick depalo tonight 5 p.m
you get Alex Jones on Friday you get a
full additional hour of sure you have
Brian Callan sure you have hot chicken
show you ever investigative unit new
comedy specials to be coming you can go
follow Josh firestein on the Instagram
Josh underscore firestein uh thank you
Rumble you well on before that if you're
on Rumble click the button right there
click the button right there yeah
you get this mug and then okay Rumble
thank you YouTube piss off
oh
[Applause]
[Music]